hello and welcome to this week's edition
of the gadget lab show i'm christina
bonnington and i'm nathan olivares giles
and today we are all about social
networking there's been some big updates
to facebook and path this week
first up we're gonna take a look at
facebook's news which is a new news feed
yeah yeah um mark zuckerberg and a few
engineers at facebook today unveiled a
whole new take on news feed and i guess
the idea here is to really make
rich media and content stand out so
bigger pictures there's going to be a
whole new news feed devoted just to
music which i'm kind of halfway excited
about and kind of also a little
frightened of and um there's i guess he
just really compared it a lot to a
newspaper like a personalized newspaper
which feels a little like flipboard-ish
yeah it definitely looks a lot like
google plus to me the images are just
much bigger they take up the full width
of the stream um instead of having the
uh description like the photo
description being like above or below
the photo it's kind of laid on top of it
kind of google plus style yeah totally
like google plus which i mean google
plus looks great so i guess it's not a
bad thing yeah but there's a whole lot
more people who use facebook so
um there's also a little bit of a
pinterest feel in there too you know um
so we'll see how it actually looks once
it rolls out to the world we haven't
gotten a chance to actually use it yet
yeah it's rolling out now and you can
sign up to be on the wait list all these
apps in their waitlists you know you
can't just get it right then they've got
to make you wait for it it's a pain i
hate i hate that particularly with that
mailbox app or whatever inbox i think
i'm still waiting i'm still waiting for
that one i'm just going to delete it but
yeah it looks really great and the the
one thing that kind of scares me a
little bit is seeing what everybody
else's music tastes are because
there's a lot of people on facebook
friends with and i just don't i know i
don't like the music they listen to i
don't care to know and that's why i'm
kind of a big fan of like artio
something a little more curated and
tailored so
it sounds like a great idea but i'm
hoping it won't be a mess right and then
so among these different types of news
feeds that you'll be able to switch
between
one of them just has everything
every single post that all of your
friends and every every group that you
follow posts uh because right now you
know sometimes i wonder what stuff is
getting hidden uh what stuff is being
prioritized to the top you know i have
friends that you know i haven't seen
since college that maybe i don't message
every day but i still want to know
what's going on in their lives so this
this stream will show all of that
information so i'm kind of a fan of that
i'd like to check that out every once in
a while it makes sense it makes sense
that feels a little like twitter
yes much more yeah much more twitter
yeah yeah
um yeah so new facebook news coming out
now and
next up matt honey will join us to take
a look at path
hey matt
hello christina so i hear you're super
excited about this new update to the
path app can you tell us a bit about
that okay let me start off by saying i
love path love it it's awesome i use it
all the time because i
kind of hate facebook and i like to
share photos i like to uh
be able to share updates with people and
know that it's gonna be private um
and that's i think path's killer feature
is that it's been it's it's it's private
you can see who sees your updates they
can't reshare your photos uh they can't
you know do all those kind of things
that make facebook a little
iffy creepy yeah disturbing um
so anyway bath rolled out with a update
3.0 yesterday it has some like
interesting features in there like uh
you can you can send stickers to people
instead of you know a message which
frees you from actually having to say
anything you can let the sticker say it
for you because yeah and you can direct
message friends now you can direct
message friends that's the big thing
yeah the stickers are great because like
everybody hates words right but um
the direct messaging thing is is pretty
nice in some ways like it's it's well
done in for what it does you can send
group messages you can send direct
messages that's nice because sometimes
you don't want to like post an update to
the you know the main path thing
um
but you do want to say something to one
person but what it also does is it lets
you send messages to friends of friends
so like i don't have to be friends with
you on path and i'm not to
send you a message
i could
even find if your friends was one of my
friends i could just enter the word of
the letter c
and your name would pop up and then i
could send you a message and there's no
way for the people who are being sent
messages to opt out of it it also sort
of reveals to some extent who people
might be friends with
and uh you know it's just
it kind of creeped me out in that same
sort of facebook way yeah that's
definitely weird i also appreciate the
more secure uh closed in nature of path
as opposed to facebook where it's just
like everyone can access all your
information and advertising and
marketing gets access to that
information too and it's just a big
security mess
yeah so uh what do you think of so you
like those stickers right
i mean they're they're goofy yeah but i
mean whatever yeah they're fun yeah
pat's answer to emoji the messaging
feature that's got like the the build of
scene voice messages i think that's
pretty great like i sent one to robbie
and you can like send a location it you
know it's a little bit easier to send
your location that way than it is to
send it through uh
maps like i i tried out both and i think
you end up doing like two fewer taps
including launching the app which i mean
a tap is a tap tap is a tap
cool well thanks so much for joining us
on this week's edition of the gadget lab
show we'll see you next week